we're looking at the 88th annual White
House Correspondents Dinner held earlier
this evening in Washington DC coming up
momentarily we'll see the introduction
of the head table by Steve Holland of
Reuters who's the president of the White
House Correspondents Association that'll
be followed by the speaking portion of
tonight's dinner first remarks from
President Bush another we followed by
comedian drew Carey
again this was held earlier this evening
in Washington DC
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. president mrs. Bush mr. vice
president
mrs. Cheney ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the annual dinner of the White House
Correspondents Association
[Music]
welcome to the annual dinner of the
White House Correspondents Association
and this our 88th year I'm Steve Holland
avoiders president the Association
I have the great honor of introducing
the head table
first to my right a man who honors us
with his presence the President of the
United States
next to the president is Bob Dean's of
Cox newspapers who is the incoming
president of the Association
[Music]
next to Bob a fierce advocate for
literacy and early education the First
Lady of the United States Laura Bush
[Applause]
next to mrs. Brewster JD Cabot one of my
bosses and the managing editor of
Reuters America
one of the funniest people in the
country drew Carey
we'll be hearing from Drew later tonight
next to Drew is Larry McQuillan of USA
Today a former president of the
Association and a current member of the
board
[Music]
the Dean of the White House press corps
Helen Thomas of Hearst Newspapers
and Steve Scully of c-span which is
broadcasting the Bennett tonight Steve's
a member of our board
[Applause]
now to my left Carl cannon of national
journal the incoming vice-president
reassociation
back from his secret lair the vice
president the United States Dick Cheney
[Applause]
Sonia Ross of The Associated Press a
member of our board
[Music]
[Applause]
the author of a new children's book
called America a patriotic Primmer Lynne
Cheney
[Applause]
Joe tienda of knight-ridder newspapers
remember of our board
the star of daytime cable TV White House
press secretary Ari Fleischer
[Applause]
Mark Smith of AP radio a member of our
board
Doug mills of AP photos a member of our
board
[Music]
[Applause]
and our indispensable legal counsel dick
Schmidt of Conan marks
Paul Canon of National Journal has done
a lot to bolster our scholarship program
he'll announce our scholarship winner
Carl
if I could please have your attention
I'm going to introduce the very
impressive young man if you could please
be quiet for one second
I'd appreciate it
I will please this is a young man from
Washington DC we won our scholarship
this year
his name is arcane Thomas we asked him
to write an essay on how you could make
a difference as a White House
correspondent and he wrote out an essay
that all the judges were so touched by
I'm going to read you just a sentence
from it if you don't mind
[Music]
the President of the United States has
the most important job in the country
and arguably in the world
Keun wrote in his pen he holds the power
to save or destroy lives at the same
time the journal is covering the
president has the power of reporting the
president's actions to the world these
journalists must always represent the
truth although they have attained this
incredible position in their careers
they must not aim to be liked or to be
accepted but to do their job and to do
it exceptionally well now the young man
who wrote that you'll meet in a minute
he's a senior at Banneker High School in
Washington
he's just accepted he's just decided to
go to Carleton College in Minnesota he
is also an unpublished novelist and a
poet his mother wanted me to tell you
that he's an Eagle Scout
and he's also and as he told Sonya Ross
and I when we went to lunch with him
very proudly he's also a PK the
preacher's kid anyway I'd like you to
introduce introduce Kane Thomas to you
[Applause]
[Applause]
thanks very much sorrow Mark Smith of AP
radio will announce our the winners of
our annual journalism awards thank you
ladies and gentlemen can we have your
attention please for the awards we have
some very deserving Award winners
tonight and we'd like to have you play
close to pay close attention to what
they're being cited for thank you very
much I'll tell him you said so sir
thank you Steve ladies and gentlemen
president mrs. Bush vice president mrs.
Cheney
I'm not sure whether I should be
delighted or alarmed to see you both in
the same room a year ago we surprised no
one at this dinner by giving our top
awards to those who covered the election
that wouldn't quit
still no doubt a fond memory for you mr.
president tonight our association of
news professionals again avoids making
news by honoring those who reported a
story that appallingly topped last
year's the attacks of September 11th
when the first hijacked planes struck
the World Trade Center our first two
Award winners were at their posts in the
executive mansion tonight we acclaim
them for writing history's first draft
of a moment of extraordinary national
drama the Merriman Smith Memorial Award
honors one print correspondent one
broadcaster for excellence in
presidential reporting on deadlines it's
named for one who personified that for
three decades the great Merriman Smith
of UPI our Prieta Ward winner tonight is
my Associated Press colleague chief
White House correspondent Ron Fournier
now his award recognizes the take after
take of riveting copy there's no other
word for it that he filed as the Secret
Service evacuated the building and as an
armed agent I might add implored him to
leave the Smith judges called Ron's work
that day carefully constructed and
compellingly written ladies and
gentlemen please join me in welcoming a
now three-time Merriman Smith honoree
Ron Fournier of The Associated Press
[Applause]
[Applause]
now as ron was typing
CBS News correspondent Peter Maher was
speaking he was describing for his radio
listeners a scene he called controlled
chaos in tones and influency those
listeners have come to expect and the
rest of us in broadcasting Peter aspire
to with resourcefulness - Peter by the
way commandeered phones at a nearby
business and even the metro station the
Smith judges say that Peters accounts
made listeners feel part of the scene
ladies and gentlemen here back for a
fourth time now accepting the Merriman
Smith award Peter Mayer of CBS News
our next award the Edgar Allan Poe award
credits excellence in national or
regional reporting it was established by
papers which once carried mr. pose
byline the New Orleans times-picayune
and News house newspapers for our poll
winners tonight terrorism was not born
September 11th listen to this sentence
please the threat posed by Osama bin
Laden is growing and coming ever closer
to home that's from a story entitled
danger terror ahead and it was published
in Newsweek on February 19th of last
year the Poe judges used words like
prescient and in-depth to describe that
story and a special report in the
magazine two weeks after the attacks
tonight we honor the journalists
responsible unfortunately Evan Thomas
could not be here but his three
colleagues are so please join me in
saluting Evan Thomas and with us tonight
Martha Brant mark hosen ball and Roy
Guttman of Newsweek
[Applause]
our final award tonight is the Aldo
Beckman award for journalistic
excellence which commemorates this
associations former president and a
respected former correspondent for the
Chicago Tribune it goes this year to a
newcomer on our beat and Kornbluth of
the Boston Globe
she is cited she is cited for a range of
reporting from her narrative of the
president's first year in office to
coverage of moments like his stem cell
decision now the judges please listen to
this the judges delighted in Ann's
graceful and clear writing a remarkable
range and her resistance to following
what they called the media pact
I think I resent that that said please
join me in honoring and Kornbluth of the
Boston Globe our 2002 Beckman Award
winner
congratulations as well to our two
honorable mentions for the pol war the
Seattle Times and the Dayton Daily News
thanks to the judges for selecting from
the you this year's extraordinary
entries please see your program for the
full details their special thanks to the
exceptional L insurer of the medulla
School of Journalism at Northwestern who
coordinated the judging and with that
Steve this broadcaster yields the mic to
you
Thank You Martin now it's time for my
favorite part of the program the
peaceful transfer of power to a new
president Bob Dean's has worked for cuz
Cox newspapers for 17 years including a
posting in Japan he's been a White House
correspondent for four years he's a
family man with a super wife and three
children and sometimes he rides his bike
to work Bob Dean's everybody
[Applause]
thank you
thanks a lot mr. president
worse where's Karen
karen is that okay if I get started
ladies and gentlemen Karen Hughes we are
going to miss her please stand
[Applause]
you know a lot of people can't
understand why Karen wants to leave
Washington I mean this is a town where a
talented person can work hard work well
subsea and reap the rewards of that
success just ask
major Garrett
it's a real privilege to be here tonight
it's a great honor to represent the men
and women of the White House press corps
I started out in the news business when
I was 10 years old delivering my
hometown paper the Richmond
times-dispatch
I got a lot of ink on my fingers I got
bitten by a few dogs but I fell in love
with newspapers one story at a time
reading the morning headlines by the
amber glow of a waning moon or the
fleeting headlights but passing milk
truck in time I grew to understand the
essential role the news media plays in
the care and feeding of American
democracy I came to believe as I do now
that a free and unfettered press is the
last line of civil defense protecting
the sanctity of our Republic from the
tyranny of an uninformed electorate now
through the modern miracle of reader
email mr. president I know not everybody
agrees with that assessment
I can imagine sir there might be
mornings when you have a hard time going
along with it yourself but on this point
our history
and our president have always been clear
no people anywhere can ever be truly
free unless they are free to know the
truth
every journalist in America has a role
to play in the daily pursuit of that
ideal weather we cover the White House
or the local school board part of the
beauty indeed one of the great strengths
of our system is that on any given day
the most junior reporter at the smallest
paper in the most remote Hamlet anywhere
in our land is free to pick up the phone
and put a question to the President of
the United States
and they have just as much right to an
answer as those of us who cover the
White House day in and day out
not
not because we journalists are special
but because the American people are
truly free to know the truth
[Applause]
it is that cherished freedom that we all
celebrate here tonight and it is in its
preservation that we shall always find
our highest calling and so tonight we
pause to pay tribute to the American
presidency
the only office our Constitution
provides to represent all the American
people and to honor the man entrusted
with the powers and the burdens of this
high office in these troubled times
and on Monday we'll roll up our sleeves
and get back to work
joining with thousands of other
journalists all across this country
asking questions on behalf of the
American people in doing our best to
faithfully Chronicle the next chapter in
the life of this extraordinary nation
one story at a time
[Applause]
and now on behalf of the White House
Correspondents Association it gives me
great pleasure to extend our gratitude
to a journalist who's been doing just
that
for 24 years he's the journalist
journalist it's the kind of guy our
commander-in-chief likes to call a good
man he has represented the White House
corps wisely and with distinction and we
are all better for his service ladies
and gentlemen friends and colleagues
please join me in presenting the
honorary gavel to the outgoing president
of the White House Correspondents
Association mr. Steve Holland
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you
I'll be brief and then we'll bring the
president up I'd like to thank my
editors and colleagues at Reuters in
particular my bureau chief Rob Doherty
for giving me the time and support to
work on behalf of the White House press
corps thanks to my fellow board members
for their hard work and support and I
couldn't have gotten through the year
without the sage advice of the former
presidents of this organization I'd also
like to thank Ari Fleischer and his team
in the White House press office for
their cooperation
and thanks to my wife Lucy and son
Carter for putting up with me into our
executive director Julie whist and Julie
we can't put this dinner on without you
and your husband Dave thank you very
much and now let's have some fun the
White House Correspondents Association
has but one toast please join me in that
toast now
to the President of the United States
and now the president
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much Steve mr. vice
president members of the White House
Correspondents Association ladies and
gentlemen Laura and I are honored to be
here tonight thanks for the invitation
what a fantastic audience we had to name
Washington powerbrokers celebrities
Hollywood stars Ozzy Osbourne
[Applause]
okay Ozzy
might have been a mistake
thinking about osseous he's made a lot
of big hit recordings party with the
animals Sabbath bloody Sabbath facing
hell black skies and bloodbath and
paradise Ozzy mom loves your stuff
[Applause]
and drew carriers our entertainment
tonight
[Applause]
drew has a fun TV show called whose line
is it anyway which is totally improvised
drew got any interest in the Middle East
last year at this dinner I showed some
photos straight out of the Bush family
photo album tonight I'm going to show
you some actual never-seen-before photos
taken by the White House photographers
over the past 15 months we've created
just for you this little slideshow of
what life is really like inside the Bush
White House so Karen if everyone's in
the seats you've assigned them
hit the projector
when I look back over the last year I I
think I've grown in office I'm much more
focused
I feel relaxed
I mean occasionally there are moments
where I feel a little stress
I may have aged a bit
one of the great things about being in
the White House is having Laura close by
whenever she drops by my office my day
is brighter
she helps me in a million ways here she
is helping me pronounce our service
Johnny's
we have two dolls this is our dog Barney
I tell him what eyebrows like that he
ought to be a senator
you can tell Barney's and some trouble
here this is the day he chewed up the
list of undisclosed locations and we
couldn't find dick
the little guy keeps a lookout like this
hour after hour
kind of wish Tom Ridge had never had
that talk with him about Homeland
Security
now this is our dog spot people often
ask me how I came up with that name I
don't know I'm just kind of a creative
guy
think about spot is that she is she
actually thinks she's the president
because she is coming back from a
fundraiser for the American Kennel Club
but she is truly a great canine American
and I value her counsel
just as I very the counsel of others on
the staff we have
[Music]
we have a very experienced mature team
of professionals down at the White House
this is Josh Bolten he's the White House
deputy chief of staff America should
sleep better at night knowing that this
calm level-headed man
is helping to guide our nation this is
Nick Kelley Oh
the head of our office of legislative
affairs I had just said to him so Nick
what are the chances of the Senate
passing Anwar
Nick Nick really prepares me well when
the congressional leaders come down for
meetings curious testing out a whoopee
cushion and we're going to use on
senator Berg
but we really have a highly motivated
group down at the white house no matter
what the task at hand each of us gives a
hundred and ten percent
the truth is the door to the Oval Office
has a little peephole this is karen
hughes peeping in on me this is Karl
Rove peeping in on it
this is condi rice people
spot has her own people
[Music]
this is an D card peeping in on me and
ladies and gentlemen
this is the vice president of the United
States looking through a peephole and
dick I hope you're not doing what it
looks like you're doing
this photo actually has nothing to do
with anything
I thought I'd show it to you however
because it's the only known photo in
existence of alan greenspan smiling
this is Ari Fleischer of course I was
chewing him out here I'm saying Ari I am
sick and tired of you not fully
answering all the wonderful questions
asked by our hard-working White House
press corps
are you sure Ari we're not leaking
enough
are you sure that we've given them
enough access to me
I've got an idea I'll do more interviews
with baseball tonight now part of the
job of a president is to meet with
representatives of special interest
groups Here I am meeting with
representatives from the American
cloning Council
I try to work with Republicans and
Democrats alike for political reasons
some Democrats prefer that it not be
known they are working with a Republican
president so they slip in the back door
like Hillary Clinton here
it's not all work of course one day I
decided to show some of the staff the
White House bowling alley boys and girls
there is a reason he wear those special
bowling shoes
of course another job of the president
is dealing with the White House press
corps you asked some pretty tough
questions but to tell you the truth I
don't think you've laid a glove on me
Here I am after our last press
conference
in closing tonight I thought about
turning serious and talking about all
we've been through since I was here last
year but then I decided this one the
time or the place you came to have a
good time
we've got drew Carey waiting to
entertain us so instead I'm gonna leave
you with one last thought and one last
photo of our dog spot I ask you ladies
and gentlemen is this a great country or
what thank you very much
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president drew Carey has
the rare honor of having not one but two
hit TV shows at the same time the Drew
Carey Show and whose line is it anyway
it's my pleasure to welcome all the way
from the great state of Ohio drew Carey
[Applause]
President Bush everybody how about it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fantastic George Bush thank you very
much
kids got a future I tell you what an
entertainer that was really great man
timing everything cheese oh by the way
if we hurry we can make to 10:30
spider-man so hurry up let's get out
here I'm really nervous about being here
I hope I'm funny but at least I know if
I bomb Saddam Hussein will send my
family money
the only solace I had I guess I'm
supposed to you know I've been watching
tape so the old you know all the other
things people are so since you got
supposed to say some stuff about the
president but you know but what can I
say what can I say about George Bush
that Al Gore hasn't already said what
he's drunk
I love watching him give us by me
telling you give the greatest speeches
every time I get a chance I watch cuz
every time he gets to a big word it's
like watching a high wire wrap is he
gonna do it yes
three syllables everybody three
syllables
that's a beauty share news and the
corner go poof huh that's why she's
leaving you now it's not the family
she's can't take the big words anymore
Ozzy Osbourne here that's great nice to
see you what's up bro
you know actually you know ozzy osbourne
and the president they a lot in common
yeah first of all they both love their
families they're both family men they
both party they're a little too hard and
they were younger
half the time you can't understand a
word either one remorse and
and neither one of them can make a move
without their wife's approval
that's right I got you pegged buddy
I'm sorry I was talking about Hillary
excuse me oops I met Nancy gee I got a
mixed up
oops I met Eleanor oops I meant Dolly
Madison how far back so it's great to be
here it's real exciting by the way I
don't know I should have to bring this
up I have friends in Hollywood I don't
have the usual Washington type friends
or all Hollywood people they live a
different lifestyle than everybody lives
I said you know I'm meeting the
president anything you want me to say so
they got together is that a party they
got together four hours later Liz what
they came up with took in four hours
they all want you to legalize pot make
everything stoller pass the message on
took them four hours to come up with it
and if you can't do both in at least
legalized pot that's what this thing
they thought and they thought and they
thought
by the way I know if anybody recognized
me a lot of people didn't recognize me I
go to my classes anymore I got LASIK
surgery if anybody thinks to get in it
I'm it's the greatest thing I ever did
it's the greatest thing I see perfectly
the only bad part is that now I have to
see myself naked in the shower
I had the best body where I got lazy
surgery the day after suddenly I left
myself go I also had angioplasty last
August same thing Dick Cheney had an
angioplasty in the center except they
left my heart in hey how about that
excellent
Smithers who is that energetic young boy
running through the halls
that's the president sir send him to me
I'm glad you laughing because I got a
family
anyway head you know we're gonna get
these part surgeries don't they tell you
to exercise that's the first thing they
tell you to do I have to see a trainer
now and work out eat I hate it you know
my trainer told me is that I have a
train I had a trainer he told me I had
to learn to listen to my body and that
the stupidest spice anybody ever heard
listen to my body I think I got so fat
in the first place
oh my body wants to do is eat give me a
pizza right away mr. Boddy
you know what I'm sleepy too
let's have a nap together meaning
so it's good to be here is good to see
everybody out having fun that's what I'm
about plate Lee I just want to go out
have a good time and that's it I just
want to enjoy my days tell you some ways
to have a good time I know it rains a
lot here in Washington
I love the when it rains don't let the
rain get you down see when it rains
really hard I like to run stop signs
just to make cops get out of the car
that's right you know I stopped you yeah
you know I ran a sign
I figured hell if I got the money get
out I also like to go to a fast food
place it's a good thing to do if ever in
a really bad mood go to a fast food
place to eat doesn't matter which one
will make it a McDonald's make a release
you go to McDonald's and say the bill is
537 they give them 11:25
just watch him stand there oh my brain
Wow
and a couple big a couple big days in
last couple weeks Saddam Hussein's
birthday I don't know how you celebrated
to hear the United States we celebrated
by having take maneuvers in Kuwait oh
well sorry should've done it Earth Day
was that everybody have a good Earth Day
everything was a couple weeks ago thank
you
a couple people care I had a great day I
drove around all day with my muffler off
that was really exciting
it's okay I have a flag on my car
I decided if you can do anything you
want make any kind of crazy driving you
want as long as you get one of those big
flags on your SUV it doesn't matter the
pick of the flag the crazier you can
drive proud to be an American least I
know I'm for you I'm not just talking
about the presidential limousine either
I'm talking about any car with a lot of
flags on it
I love the new patriotism everybody has
it's great I just love it everywhere I
see signs it is a spread it's fantastic
everywhere I see signs god Bless America
chicken wings 349 could be where he used
to be just chicken wings 349 so gotta
take better with you I get a lot of
political are you know everybody stuck
in politics now that's the big subject
of the day I was at a party and some
somebody said to me they said you know
if women ran the world there'd be no war
it's like yeah right I'm sure no one
would start a stupid fight for no reason
if women ran in the world
yeah hi this is England how come I'm
being invaded oh I think you know why
I saw the way you were looking at France
I can't watch the news late I know
everybody you know I recognize loud you
watch the news it gets so depressing and
so I mean I just get depressed watching
the news
no tidy when I watch the news now I turn
the news off I get up my Bible I turn to
the Book of Revelations I start just
checking stuff off you know
got it got it need it got it got it
red dragon seven horns ten crowns
Ozzy Osbourne America's favorite TV bad
man 20 million dollars and you know
that's barely gonna pay for your kids
therapy I don't know why that money's
gonna be down the drain man for you
yeah I read the Bible a lot you know
this is crazy we celebrate holidays and
you know we just find out to us recently
there's so many holidays we celebrate
here in this country that have nothing
to do with the Bible at all real famous
holidays like Christmas Christmas has
nothing it's not in the Bible the birth
of Jesus is in the Bible but not
Christmas the treason in the Bible you
know gifts that's not under snow where
it says celebrate my birthday says Jesus
it's just week it's a pagan holiday that
the Romans invented that we just do but
everywhere you go I'm talking I've seen
this so many times you see a big
nativity scene and there's baby Jesus
the manger sheep Shepherd Wiseman Mary
Joseph Santa Claus right in the middle
like who's that Mary's Lamaze coach
santa claus has nothing to do with
anything neither there's the Easter
Bunny Easter it's another pagan holiday
that's not the Bible every creature
every Easter you don't hear anything
about Jesus on the cross I hear is about
the Easter Bunny Easter Bunny this
Easter Bunny that why is the Christian
religion the only one in the world that
needs a mascot to sell their stuff you
don't see Jewish people out celebrating
with the Passover kangaroo
there's no ramadan rooster
Halloween's another big holiday satanic
holiday nobody's bothered by that for
some reason you know fun for the kiddies
I mean when I was go to church I always
told me you know Satan is the most evil
one he's the one you got to watch out
for watch out for Satan and then once
the year the whole country goes hey
let's party with this guy it's
ridiculous they had there's a Catholic
Church down my street they used to have
Halloween parties every year of course
they don't have anymore because they
didn't want the priests to hand out
candy to the kids
Dabu I have to offer I'm going to offer
a word of support to the Catholic Church
there's no such thing as bad publicity
such thing capital c small ath Oh
by the way I want to just take a second
and I wouldn't I was really honored to
be asked to come here and it's I mean it
means so much to me and there's so many
people I admire in the audience I want
to say hi to general Tommy Franks to sit
at this table right here no cracks Thank
You general Tommy Franks
and colin powell it's just an honor just
to be in the same room with you sir
and of course Vice President Cheney and
President Bush I just really it's just
something I have to say how was that
your inaugural parade I don't remember
it was so cold out there it was freezing
I was getting booed every 25 feet and
all I could think of was hey could be
worse could be a Gore parade you know I
was so happy with you and it's real
honored to be here the reason I
mentioned general Frank's is and
compound and is especially because of
the war that's going on and I got to do
a USO tour a couple of USO tours last
year and I knew this before say seen the
Mercer's but I just want to say in all
seriousness we have the best military in
the world I just want to talk nobody
nova
I get choked up I can't really go
through the whole thing but it really
the most honorable people and the
regular troops they're the most
hard-working they do everything they
follow every order no matter how stupid
and they just go okay we'll do it
because we're the military that's what
we could pay to do and I salute you and
god bless all of you for everything you
do
[Applause]
so you know everybody's worried about
when we're gonna get Osama bin Laden
that's always in there who cares when
we're gonna get Osama bin Laden took a
year to get Robert Blake he was only in
a house in Studio City
and what took him so long by the way I
knew he was guilty that minute he said
oops I left my gun in the restaurant you
know he'll like something goofy I left
my gun at the restaurant you're going in
your wife gets shot at the same time
what a coincidence he's not gonna go
away with that he used a gun a rare gun
of World War two vintage gun
it only has certain bullets that can you
use those are very rare there's three
bullets missing from the box two of the
bullets were in her the other bullets in
the gun you know what I think I think he
wasn't trying to fool like modern police
detectives he was trying to fool beretta
he was walking around
what would beretta do and if you do
catch this on bin Laden when he catches
on the lawn because you get by the way
if he has cable up here's buddy
special message from me to you a to be
killed no he's gonna bleed you know
there's Arabs out there not gonna
believe anything you do they don't
believe the other tapes we got over
Solomon lon they all say it's fake you
know is that annoying you get these
tapes here's a song they go now you
faked it the United States faith it's
like trying to convince Democrats they
really lost the election
that's right you won they lost that's
what happened there was no theft and
rigging in our that crab aqui he won you
lost the problem wasn't mr. freed the
problem was people that couldn't vote
like this and voted like this
that was the problem
but say you know I was over it in some
Arab countries with Tommy Franks and
there we have great Arab neighbors a lot
of people get down and Arabs now because
of Osama that's not there are a lot of
really good Arab neighbors it's real
it's a pleasure they really treat us
nice
there's even got you know I was in this
Baja rain they were strip club there did
you know yeah cuz that's where the
Saudis go to party on the weekends so
they haven't is like did I did he eat
it's not much you know but for you know
an Arab country it's pretty exhilarating
you know it
yeah it's so much stuff on they got to
put on stairway to heaven just to get
down to their underwear
I can't write you know they're so
friendly I can't figure out why other
countries like hate us like this can you
figure it out we're just so nice to
everybody
we don't want much America we just want
to go to your country you want to open a
couple of burger stands sell the best
burgers in the world some delicious
recipe chicken you know so that's all we
want to do chain your kids to a sewing
machine open up an air base or two come
on that's all we want to do
set up a puppet government that will do
whatever we say what do you have come on
get with the winning team huh
[Music]
is it too much to ask
so while I salute over the years I got a
couple complaints this is what I'm so
glad to be here because you know it's
like I can finally complain to the
manager you know all this time I've just
been muttering into my newspaper at the
coffee can
these security codes here's my couple my
ideas that really help out the security
codes we have red yellow whatever what
do they mean and what are you supposed
to do I have no idea I know that yellow
is pretty bad and there's orange and
stuff so look at the red is the one I'm
worried about if it's red so my idea if
it's a red day everything is 50% off
yeah it warns people and get some hope
all at the same time solve a lot of
problems two for one the other thing is
the airports I think you know this is
the thing I God bless you you Tom Ridge
wherever you are you got the worst job
you do I would in for a million dollars
I think that done and I think you know I
don't mind going through the line and
everything at the airports I can see why
you do everything and I'm all for every
script but why the questions who you for
one who you catching what are did you
pack your own bag has your bag and been
under your control the whole time
what does the terror is supposed to do
okay yeah you got me
I don't know what I was thinking
your brain was bigger than mine take me
away if you're gonna ask two questions
here's just you should ask are you gonna
hijack the plane
really
I can't even answer those questions
honestly cuz I'm rich I hate the NRO
hate to break it to you a lot of people
go Drew Carey regular guy but I got tons
of money man when they asked me to Japan
bag I can't go well no my assistant
packed it he doesn't like to you but I
make them has it been under your control
the whole time
now the limo driver mostly added but it
looks cool he's clean-cut
don't worry about
have any bombs on and I got a copy of
glitter in my pocket
sorry glitter fans I didn't know the
whole room would be full of glitter
family listen I'm gonna wrap up but I
just want to say before I leave you know
I'm a comedian and I'm on TV so a lot of
people go oh we like you but please
don't treat celebrities like they're
heroes because we know who the real
heroes are in this country and you know
seriously I think it's a mistake to see
the Tresa liveries like that I want
everybody to be treated the same way I
get treated so I want you to the next as
soon as you can the next time you see a
top fireman man or woman on the street I
want you to go up to him give him a nice
round of applause and say hey man you're
funny thank you very much mr. president
vice president appreciate it everybody
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]